[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 el 8 de abril de
1973 en el sur de Francia falleció a los
91 años uno de los artistas más
reconocidos y celebrados del mundo el
español Pablo Picasso 50 años después
Cuál es el legado que el maestro del
cubismo dejó al mundo Esta es una de las
preguntas para nuestra invitada en este
programa especial de cultura la artista
plástica y docente de la escuela de
artes plásticas de la Universidad
Nacional de Colombia María Fernanda
zuluaga Buenos días y gracias por haber
aceptado nuestra invitación cómo estás
Muchas gracias a ti
50 años después de su muerte porque se
sigue considerando hoy a Picasso uno de
los artistas más importantes del mundo
bueno 50 años después de su muerte
seguimos hablando de él primero pienso
yo Que porque el arte es horizontal en
este momento nosotros podemos estudiar
artistas del medioevo del renacimiento
artistas de como Goya artistas como el
mismo Picasso que continuamente son una
fuente de conocimiento
un artista como Velázquez por ejemplo
Barroco rembrandt nos están enseñando
todo el tiempo muchísimas miradas
muchísimas perspectivas de su trabajo de
su visión del mundo y por eso son
completamente actuales y por eso el arte
considero yo que es horizontal no es que
una cosa que pasó hace mucho o un
artista que que vivió hace mucho que
dejó un legado hace mucho ya no importa
no sigue siendo sigue siendo
completamente relevante y una fuente
inmensa de conocimiento como Picasso y
este legado lo podemos ver en ciertos
artistas hoy en día artistas que serían
Los herederos de una cierta forma de
Picasso claro por ejemplo un artista que
vive actualmente que se llama David
hockney que es inglés
el permanentemente dice que el cubismo
que nació con Picasso o mejor nació con
cesán no acabó con Picasso y no acabó
cuando murió Picasso sino que el cubismo
sigue digamos empezó en ese momento pero
ha seguido y tiene mucho para
desarrollarse porque es una mirada nueva
que se que se hace en el siglo XX cuando
cuando Picasso hace sus obras cuando se
sana empieza con esa mirada múltiple de
muchas perspectivas cuando empieza a
hacer una mirada activa no esa mirada
pasiva que se tenía antes del artista
quieto frente a lo que veía
sino empieza a romper Esa esa quietud y
empieza a mirar como realmente vemos el
mundo porque uno ve yo te veo a ti desde
muchos ángulos tú estás en movimiento Yo
también eso es lo que lo que plantea el
cubismo en una primera instancia una
búsqueda de en un plano bidimensional
Mostrar esa simultaneidad de planos que
que se eliminan un poco la perspectiva
la profundidad por supuesto pero al
mismo tiempo abren una nueva mirada
rompen con esa mirada como como tuerta
como quieta que se tenía antes y qué
relación tiene latinoamérica con este
artista europeo
Bueno muchísimas muchísimas Picasso
influyó y sigue influyendo podríamos
decir por ejemplo que que se ve
muchísimo esto en Wilfredo la artista
cubano que estuvo con una marcada
influencia de Picasso Diego Rivera
mexicano que vivió compartió con Picasso
en España un tiempo y
estuvo regreso acá como muy tocado por
esto que planteaba el gobierno y el
movimiento Pues que hizo picada y George
bracket de no solamente un arte que que
está contemplando sino también una un
arte que tiene una una posición
supremamente activa y crítica de la
realidad de la política de lo social con
un sueño también de transformar no de
denunciar de decir lo que hay de dolor
de guerra de la injusticia Y ser un poco
voceros de hablar del por los que no
tienen voz Bueno vamos a hablar ahora de
las celebraciones museos del mundo
entero han programado a lo largo de este
2023 unas 50 exposiciones sobre el
artista nacido en Málaga pica su estudio
en Barcelona antes de instalarse en
París y justamente es en el Museo
Picasso de la capital francesa que sus
obras más importantes están expuestas
Natalia Ruiz giraldo y armel q nos
ofrecen un recorrido
Pablo Picasso sigue siendo inspiración
para los artistas de hoy aunque se haya
convertido en un personaje complejo
acusado de misoginia pero su aporte al
arte moderno no tiene duda celebración
Picasso la colección toma color Esa es
la actual exposición en el Museo del
mismo nombre del pintor malagueño bajo
la dirección artística del célebre
diseñador británico pault mansión
de Picasso no es tanto de cómo se veía
sino de cómo pensaba
de alguien lleno de energía que siempre
estaba interesado en reinventarse lo
principal era respetar absolutamente El
Talento artístico de Picasso pero
agregándole un poco de modernidad o una
manera un poco moderna de verlo hoy en
día
y eso tiene que ver con el color con los
patrones o con algo divertido en algunos
casos Como por ejemplo con las cabras
en la sala las cabras están como en una
sesión fotográfica con pasto falso piso
Así que creo que él hubiera disfrutado
de este sentido del humor creo
las rayas son la marca de fábrica de
Smith
y puedes también en estas pinturas de
Picasso
Así es pero es algo más del Azar porque
yo estaba viendo muchas obras Y de
pronto vi Muchas obras en donde me di
cuenta que había todas esas rayas y ahí
es donde poco a poco fui seleccionando
las pinturas para esta sala y así me di
cuenta de que había un sentido común un
sentir similar con mi trabajo
Picasso también fue señalado por el
movimiento mitú acusado de misoginia y
de abuso psicológico de sus excompañeras
como
el museo Picasso Busca dar Claridad a
este debate
[Música]
la relación de Picasso con las mujeres
es algo por supuesto muy presente
digamos en las nuevas generaciones de
neofeminismo y comprendemos muy bien que
el comportamiento de Picasso con las
mujeres hoy es algo visto como
inapropiado y difícil de aceptar esas
preguntas son muy importantes y nosotros
en nuestro museo queremos verlas de
frente es por eso que es mucho más fácil
responder a estos cuestionamientos a
través de los artistas mismos
la manera como Paul Smith ha dispuesto
las obras mostrando piezas también de
Luis boofra o de doramar da a estas
mujeres su lugar que son por lo general
mujeres fuertes
para muchos artistas contemporáneos
Picasso es imprescindible la artista
nigeriana
halló en él quien le transmita la fuerza
de reinventarse
la vi la reina
Esta obra habla de la vida la muerte y
el Renacer para mí como artista es una
inspiración el poder continuar ser yo
misma ya no tener miedo de lo
desconocido y cuando veo a Picasso eso
me brinda seguridad que uno se puede
inventar cada día ser mejor y
transformarse en otra cosa
se cumplen 50 años de su muerte pero
Picasso para admiración o controversia
sigue presente a través del tiempo
María Fernanda es interesante ver como
dentro de esta exposición en París se
maneja el tema de la controversia
alrededor de la figura de Picasso Qué
opina usted al respeto Bueno me parece
muy importante tener en cuenta pues a un
artista como un ser que es íntegro que
es tiene desde todas sus perspectivas
como una figura pública y no hay que
tapar el sol con un dedo
digamos se sabe que que Picasso fue un
artista que no no tuvo un comportamiento
Con las mujeres como de respeto o que
fue fiel O sí Se supone que todo lo que
no ha leído y ha visto de él era Pues sí
maltratador mujeriego Pero también es un
artista que rompió la historia del arte
en dos y en eso no también ahí no se
puede tapar el sol con un dedo y y su
obra es un legado impresionante
no solamente en Europa sino en el resto
del mundo en América Latina
también por Esa visión comprometida con
la realidad con lo social con la guerra
con todas las injusticias que estaban
ocurriendo en su momento
de la Segunda Guerra Mundial de la
población del guernica que fue
bombardeada y el inmediatamente tuvo que
como que reaccionar ante eso y hacer por
ejemplo el guernica la obra importante
de él
Entonces sí pienso que que los dos
aspectos están ahí no y que hay
inconsciencia por un lado en su
comportamiento como hombre como ser
humano con las mujeres pero que al mismo
tiempo hay una conciencia de una
sabiduría y una genialidad en su trabajo
en el arte y para terminar sobre su
legado ustedes artista pero también
profesora en la escuela de artes
plásticas de la Universidad Nacional de
Colombia Cómo se enseña la obra de
Picasso a los estudiantes y como ellos
perciben a Picasso ellos que son los
futuros artistas del mañana claro
Picasso siempre se ha estudiado y pienso
que se seguirá estudiando por todo lo
que ya hemos comentado
respecto digamos a la influencia que que
él ha tenido por ejemplo en lo que uno
enseña en las clases que es la como lo
que uno ha visto que le afecta a uno
como artista en su trabajo hay una
exposición bellísima respecto este tema
también del mito que yo bien en Madrid
en 2019
en el caixa fueron de Madrid sobre Olga
Picasso y era una exposición hermosísima
muy muy conmovedora que dejaba ver
también pues ese amor Ese Picasso
enamorado profundamente de su mujer de
su hijo Pablo y hay unas obras
bellísimas que muestran todas las
facetas del digamos desde el dibujo el
grabado los objetos las culturas digamos
esas eso es algo que es muy importante y
que se estudia también en la academia o
por lo menos yo en mis clases porque es
muy contemporáneo no esa postura de un
artista como
multidimensional como que está
trabajando en distintos soportes
desarrollando su proceso creativo
con muchas búsquedas siempre Siendo un
poco más allá con una multiplicidad
digamos de miradas sería como lo que uno
más
sacaría de Picasso como como una gran
enseñanza no Y ese artista hockney que
te comenté ahorita que inglés que sigue
desarrollando su obra la obra de Picasso
pero desde lo que él ve que es que puede
ir el cubismo más adelante entonces las
de fotografías cientos de fotografías de
un objeto de un espacio Polaroid de
detalles luego las ensambla y vemos un
cuadro que nos muestra como realmente se
ve la realidad no eso también
conceptualmente es muy fuerte y digamos
que también espiritualmente es algo muy
completo y muestra como la la
multiplicidad en en las posibilidades
como
que somos unos seres de muchas facetas
que la obra al mismo tiempo tiene muchas
facetas interconectadas
y esta obra también múltiple en el
sentido de ser una enciclopedia entera
no dar como cuenta del mundo del de una
complejidad
bueno María Fernanda zuluaga Muchas
gracias por acompañarnos 24 a ti gracias
y gracias a ustedes por su confianza
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]